the latest hero to receive the medal of
honor faces a harrowing personal battle
at home
president Trump awarded the highest
military honor yesterday to former Army
Staff Sergeant Ronald Shore for his
bravery in Afghanistan David Martin
shows us what the sergeant faced in the
war zone and the struggle he's dealing
with now the team of Green Berets and
Afghan commandos went in by helicopter
to capture or kill suspected Afghan
terrorist leaders but for Staff Sergeant
Ronald sure that day in the spring of
2008 became a five-hour battle to save
the lives of his own men firming person
I just became a a mission of just
getting as many guys out of there as I
could the enemy held the high ground and
the Green Berets were under withering
fire sure was the team's medic Ron raced
to each patient giving them life-saving
care they were bleeding profusely I
heard the first calls for medic and at
that point worked my way over to the
first person did you have to expose
yourself to fire to get there yes I mean
I get there did you get it I know when I
was shot in the helmet and what are you
okay felt like somebody hit me and the
helmet with a baseball bat
well Apache helicopters rocketed the
village and jets dropped bombs within
danger close range sure kept moving
across open ground to treat the wounded
medevacs braved the firestorm to
evacuate the casually sure had treated
not a single American died in that
brutal battle thanks in great measure to
Ron's heroic actions sure got out of the
army and joined the Secret Service when
the president told him he would be
receiving the Medal of Honor what he
said out of Honor I was so confused that
I really don't remember what else he
said confused why confused to be singled
out it all just
just doesn't make sense there's one
other thing about 39 year-old Ronald
sure that won't make sense to anyone
that's diagnosed with lung cancer last
year what's the prognosis taking it one
day at a time he's faced death before
and knows exactly what he has to do
we're just giving this fight everything
we can just just like the last one for
CBS this morning David Martin in
Washington